There's a new Valkyrie in the pages of Marvel
comics - and her face is a familiar one.
"You're far more clever than anyone else in
this realm."
"Realm?
Realm?"
The House of Ideas has confirmed that none
other than Jane Foster will return from her
apparent death to take on the mantle in her
own series, Jane Foster: Valkyrie.
The first issue is slated for publication
in July.
The move comes in the aftermath of the massive
Marvel crossover event War of the Realms,
which saw the Dark Elf Malekith the Accursed
mounting a conquest of all ten realms.
With only Midgard (aka Earth) left standing,
a massive roster of Marvel's heroes assembled
to combat the threat, including, of course,
Thor and Loki, who were key to thwarting Malekith's
plot.
The well-received event featured such standout
moments as Wolverine coming to the rescue
of the Punisher, Ghost Rider teaming up with
Doctor Strange, and Daredevil briefly attaining
godlike power.
Of course, it wouldn't be a Mighty Marvel
crossover without a few casualties, and War
of the Realms was no exception.
Among the most notable: Brunnhilde the Valkyrie,
who in issue #2 of the main series was decapitated
by Malekith himself.
With the valiant warrior gone, the door was
open for a new Valkyrie to emerge, and Foster
should fit the bill nicely.
The character has a long history in the comics,
having first appeared in Journey into Mystery
#84 in 1962 - before Thor even had his own
solo title.
Although she primarily served as a love interest
for the God of Thunder for much of her publication
history, the character has become much more
prominent in Marvel lore in recent years.
Following her portrayal onscreen by Natalie
Portman in 2011's Thor and 2013's Thor: The
Dark World, Marvel decided that it was time
for her to take the spotlight - and in 2014,
she did just that, in dramatic fashion.
In a storyline in Thor's solo book that year,
Foster was diagnosed with breast cancer at
around the same time that Thor lost the ability
to wield Mjolnir during a battle with Nick
Fury.
The mighty weapon, abandoned on the Moon,
telepathically called out to Foster - who,
with the aid of Heimdall, retrieved it and
became the first woman to harness the power
of Thor.
Foster held down the mantle for a number of
years, but unfortunately, each transformation
into Thor resulted in her cancer progressing
at an accelerated rate.
She eventually succumbed to the disease after
a brutal battle with Mangog, the physical
manifestation of the collective hatred of
a race which was slaughtered by the armies
of Asgard in centuries past - but she was
revived by Odin in recognition of her valiant
efforts against the forces of evil.
She then convinced Thor to reclaim his title,
focusing her energies on battling the disease
which still threatened her life.
Given her experience wielding the power of
Asgard's mightiest warrior, Foster is a brilliant
choice to take on the mantle of Valkyrie.
Marvel's publication arm seems to increasingly
be taking its cues from the outrageously successful
Marvel Cinematic Universe, a trend illustrated
by this latest move.
It's safe to say that Jane Foster's name recognition
skyrocketed thanks to her inclusion in the
MCU, and the Valkyries themselves weren't
exactly household names until Tessa Thompson's
portrayal of the last surviving member of
Asgard's elite all-female fighting force in
2017's Thor: Ragnarok.
But among comics fans, Foster has picked up
a sizable fan base thanks to her time holding
down the mantle of Thor, and those fans should
be thrilled to see her back in action.
We'll see just how hard Mighty Marvel hits
the sweet spot when the first issue of Jane
Foster: Valkyrie hits stands in July 2019.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
comic book characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.